schlechte Nachrichten die Tage werden
wieder kürzer nächste Woche ist auch
noch Zeit imstellung und wir kriegen
immer weniger Sonne ab sollte man jetzt
also anfangen Vitamin D zu nehmen um
kaum ein Vitamin wird so viel gestritten
wie um Vitamin D da haben sich richtige
Lager gebildet einige schwören darauf
und sehen es als Heilmittel für
Krankheiten wie Depressionen an und
andere halten die Tropfen oder Tabletten
für reine Geldverschwendung was stimmt
jetzt also eine typische Frage für Dr
Watson eigentlich wollten wir hier nur
ein bisschen Klarheit in diese
Diskussion bringen bei der Recherche
sind wir dann aber auf ein
überraschendes Problem gestoßen fast
alle Studien zu Vitamin D haben den
einen gleichen Grundfehler der sie quasi
wertlos macht wie kann es sein dass
hochkaretige international anerkannte
Studien zu Vitamin D in Fachkreisen als
forschungsmüll bezeichnet werden und was
bedeutet das für uns gehören die hier
jetzt auch automatisch in den Müll genau
darüber sprechen wir jetzt bei dr
Watson
ganz kurz dieses Video hier gibt es
unter anderem nur wegen Planet wild
durch sie könnt ihr Naturschutzprojekte
finanziell unterstützen und spätestens
vier Wochen später in einem Video sehen
was euer Beitrag in der Natur bewirkt
hat mehr dazu erfahrt ihr am Ende des
Videos die Diskussion um vitamin D ist
extrem polarisiert Journalisten
WissenschaftlerInnen und surprise
surprise Hersteller von
nahungsergänzungsmitteln geraten
deswegen regelmäßig aneinander übrigens
besonders gerne im Internet
aber auch in der Wissenschaft ist man
sich nicht einig dieser Mann hier dr
Jörg spitz hat sogar ein Buch
geschrieben mit dem Titel Vitamin D
immer wenn es um Leben oder Tod geht das
ist meine Ansage aber ist da vielleicht
sogar wirklich was dran bevor wir in die
Details gehen lass uns einmal kurz
schauen was Vitamin D eigentlich ist
Vitamin D ist nämlich erstmal gar kein
einzelnes Vitamin sondern der
Oberbegriff für eine Reihe fettlöslicher
Vitamine die
calziferole meistens sind mit Vitamin D
aber die zwei Hauptformen gemeint
erstens Vitamin D2 das kommt z.B in
Pilzen und Pflanzen vor und dann noch
Vitamin D3 die für uns wichtigste Form
sie steckt in fettem Fisch z.B Makrele
oder Hering wird aber auch von uns
Menschen selbst produziert und zwar über
die Sonne wenn UVB Strahlen auf die Haut
treffen dann wandeln Sie das in der Haut
bereits enthaltene 7dhc in Vitamin D3 um
das kann der Körper dann
verstoffwechseln man geht davon aus dass
bis zu 90% unseres Vitamin dbedarfs
durch diese endogene Produktion also im
Körper gedeckt wird die Menge ist
abhängig von Faktoren wie UV-Strahlung
hautbedeckung und Hautfarbe was auch
erklärt warum viele Menschen im
deutschen Winter nicht genug Vitamin D
produzieren aber dazu kommen wir später
als Vorstufe eines Hormons steuert
Vitamin D bestimmte Prozesse in unserem
Körper z.B im Immunsystem es reguliert
aber auch z.B die Aufnahme von Phosphat
und Calzium beide spielen eine wichtige
Rolle bei der knochengesund
vitamin D wird deswegen auch vorbeugend
für einige Erkrankungen eingesetzt z.B
bei Babys die gerade im ersten
Lebensjahr kaum an der Sonne sind seit
den 50er Jahren wird so erfolgreich
einer schweren Knochenerkrankung der
Rachitis vorgebeugt auch bei einigen
chronischen Erkrankungen die z.B die
Aufnahme oder die Verstoffwechslung von
Vitamin D stören und somit einen Mangel
hervorrufen wird mit Präparaten
nachgeholfen das Vitamin D eine wichtige
Rolle bei der Vorbeugung von bestimmten
Krankheiten spielen kann ist also gar
nicht mal so umstritten zumindest nicht
so wie es manchmal scheint da die
zuständigen Rezeptoren aber in fast
allen Zellen des Körpers vorhanden sind
gehen viele davon aus dass Vitamin D
noch bei mehr Krankheiten helfen könnte
und genau da wird's jetzt spannend denn
zu Vitamin D gibt es genau deswegen
extrem viele Studien die haben aber oft
unterschiedliche Qualität will man
deswegen herausfinden ob eine Behandlung
auch wirklich bei einer Krankheit wirkt
führt kein Weg an randomisierten
kontrollierten Studien vorbei den
RCTs die Teilnehmer mit der gleichen
Krankheit werden dabei zufällig
verschiedenen Gruppen zugeordnet die
Untersuchungsgruppe bekommt dann über
einen Zeitraum das zu untersuchende
Medikament also in diesem Fall Vitamin D
eine oder mehrere Kontrollgruppen
bekommen eine andere Therapie ein
Placebo oder manchmal auch einfach gar
nichts am Ende guckt man dann inwiefern
sich Symptome oder z.B Blutwerte
verändert haben weil sich die
verschiedenen Gruppen sehr gut
vergleichen lassen gelten die RCTs als
Gold Standard um eine Wirkung
nachzuweisen logisch also dass sie auch
bei Vitamin D gemacht werden und das
nicht zu knapp es gibt solche Studien zu
Vitamin D bei covid-19 bei Depressionen
bei Asthma bei Diabetes bei
Herzerkrankungen etc etc etc wir können
die leider nicht jedes paper im Detail
besprechen aber es fällt eine Sache auf
die Ergebnisse sind ziemlich ernüchternd
die meisten finden keinen statistisch
signifikanten Nutzen von Vitamin D wie
z.B hier zur Vorbeugung von Krebs und
Herzerkrankungen diese sehr bekannte
vitalstudie mit fast 26 000
US-Amerikanern kommt zu dem Fazit dass
eine Supplementierung mit Vitamin D
nicht zu weniger Krebs oder
Herzproblemen führt ein anderes Beispiel
ist diese Studie die die Auswirkung von
Vitamin D auf das Depressionsrisiko und
die Stimmungslage bei über 18 000
Personen untersucht hat auch hier wurde
kein signifikanter Unterschied zum
Placebo gefunden und so gehen viele der
RCTs aus gut dann wirkt Vitamin D wohl
einfach nicht könnte man meinen viele
dieser Studien sind nur leider total
unbrauchbar das hat uns Dr Ben schötg
gesagt er ist Epidemiologe am Deutschen
Krebsforschungszentrum und forscht
selbst zu Vitamin D in den klinischen
Studien haben wir gleich eine ganze
Reihe von Problemen Hauptproblem ist
dass die nicht am Anfang alle die
Vitamin dsiegel gemessen haben der
Studienteilnehmer und nur Leute die
wirklich einen Mangel haben können
natürlich auch von der vitamin-d-gabe
profitieren und in Deutschland ist es so
dass 15% der Bevölkerung Mangel haben
das heißt wenn man
eine Studie macht in der
Normalbevölkerung ähm ist es dann sehr
schwer nur mit diesen 15 % die da in der
Studie sind wirklich ein Effekt zu
zeigen man kriegt dann meistens einen
kleinen Effekt rein der viel zu
unterschätzt ist okay ich erkläre das
mal eben an dem Beispiel von gerade
durch Beobachtungsstudien weiß man ja
dass Vitamin- D-Mangel irgendwie mit
Depression zusammenhängt und jetzt will
man logischerweise wissen ob es helfen
würde diesen Mangel auszugleichen aber
das ist halt irgendwie witzlos wenn die
meisten Studienteilnehmer gar keinen
Mangel haben unterm Strich wurden also
fast immer die falschen Leute untersucht
es gibt sogar eigene Publikationen nur
dazu wie schlecht die Studienlage zu
Vitamin D wegen dieses Fehlers ist in
dieser Metaanalyse kommen die Autoren
sogar zu dem Schluss dass fast alle der
von ihnen untersuchten RCTs zu Vitamin D
so schlecht sind sind dass sie sie als
forschungsmüll
bezeichnen AUA dazu kommt dass viele der
Studien in den USA durchgeführt werden
dort wird Vitamin D einigen
Nahrungsmitteln wie z.B Milch oder auch
Cornflakes in der Herstellung zugesetzt
das heißt die Leute haben eh schon einen
hohen Vitamin D-Spiegel deswegen kann
man diese Studien in den USA eigentlich
zur Seite legen und sagen also das ist
nicht auf Deutschland übertragbar und in
den amerikanischen Studien kam auch nie
relevantes raus das ist noch ein Problem
wenn man jetzt eine neue Studie macht
heutzutage dass das schon so bekannt ist
dass Vitamin D gegen Reihe von
Krankheiten wirken könnte und dann die
Leute die in die Kontrollgruppe kommen
dazu zu bringen nichts außerhalb der
Studie noch ein Vitamin D zu kaufen und
einzunehmen ist eine Herausforderung
viele Leute in der plboruppe nehmen also
trotzdem Vitamin D ja nice alles
zusammenengenommen verliert der gold
Standard dabei ganz schön seinen
goldigen Glanz wir kommen gleich noch
dazu was das jetzt für uns und für
Vitamin D bedeutet und ob ihr
supplementieren solltet oder nicht aber
lass uns erstmal kurz einen Blick auf
Deutschland werfen vielleicht habt ihr
auch schon mal davon gehört dass in
Deutschland im Vergleich zu den USA fast
alle einen Vitamin- D-Mangel haben das
geht auf eine Studie des RKI zurück die
7000 Personen in Deutschland untersucht
hat dafür wurde die Menge eines Vitamin
D Vorläufers 25 ohd im Blutserum
gemessen je mehr davon da ist desto
besser ist man versorgt bei den genauen
Grenzwerten ist man sich allerdings
nicht so ganz einig deswegen kursieren
verschiedene Werte wir nehmen hier jetzt
mal die IOM Definition die auch das RKI
nutzt demnach ist ein 25 ohd Wert unter
30 nanomol pro Liter ein Mangel Werte ab
50 sind ausreichend im Bereich
dazwischen also alles zwischen 30 und 50
spricht man eher von einer
Unterversorgung also nicht optimal aber
auch nicht dramatisch und in diesem Feld
bewegen sich laut der Studie im
Jahresdurchschnitt tatsächlich knapp die
Hälfte aller Menschen in Deutschland und
das ist total erwartbar denn in den
Jahresdurchschnitt fließen nämlich auch
die Werte aus dem Winter mit ein und die
sind naturgemäß eher gering in unseren
Breitengraden sind die uvbstahlen
zwischen Oktober und Mai einfach nicht
stark genug bei der geringen
Strahlungsintensität müsste man für
mehrere Stunden nackt draußen rumlaufen
um genug Vitamin D produzieren zu können
und das ja kann man machen muss man aber
nicht wirklich problematisch wird es
erst wenn man kontinuierlich einen
Mangel oder eine Unterversorgung hat z.B
durch Stoffwechselstörungen oder weil
man das Haus einfach kaum noch verlässt
ein großes Problem in Pflegeheimen in
den Sommermonaten reicht es für eine
gesunde Person aber aus einfach normal
nach draußen zu gehen um ihren
vitamind-spiegel zu decken die
empfohlenen 10 bis 12 Minuten die man so
findet beziehen sich dabei allerdings
meistens auf Menschen mit Hautyp Z und
sehr spezifische
uvindexangaben damit kann ein Großteil
der Gesellschaft halt nichts anfangen
deswegen hier ein praktischer
alltagstipp ein guter Richtwert ist die
Hälfte der Zeit in der man normalerweise
einen Sonnenbrand bekommt okay und wie
sieht's jetzt mit der Vitamin D
Forschung aus nun wichtig ist auf jeden
Fall die Kritik an den Studien bedeutet
nicht dass Vitamin D deswegen
automatisch bei den untersuchten
Krankheiten wirksam ist sondern nur dass
man für viele Fälle einfach bessere
Studien machen muss bevor man über Haupt
irgendeine Aussage treffen kann und
natürlich auch erstmal guckt wer einen
Mangel hat und somit überhaupt davon
profitieren könnte irgendwie obvious ja
und wenn die Probleme klar sind dann
wird man das doch in Zukunft besser
machen oder nun ganz so einfach ist das
leider nicht dr schötg hat uns erzählt
dass die Studien in der
Forschungslandschaft schon viel Schaden
angerichtet haben es ist extrem
schwierig an Forschungsgelder für neue
Studien zu kommen denn die sind teuer
und waren auf dem Papier ja alle schon
erfolglos nicht mal big Pharma lässt da
mit sich reden weil Vitamin D nicht
genug Profit abwerfen würde am DKFZ will
dr schötg es trotzdem versuchen
finanziert mit Spendengeldern da läuft
gerade eine Studie mit
Darmkrebspatienten in der all die
Probleme mitgedacht werden sollen in
einer Zwischenauswertung konnte man
immerhin schon sehen dass die
placeboruppe diesmal kein Vitamin D
zusätzlich einnimmt Ergebnisse gibt es
dann in zwei Jahren bis dahin hoffen wir
dass die Studien ein bisschen besser
werden damit auch die Diskussion über
Vitamin D endlich besser werden kann
aber was bedeutet das jetzt für dich und
mich sollten wir die hier nehmen wenn
ihr als gesunde Person Jahreszeiten
bedingt auch mal unterversorgt seid dann
gibt es keinen Grund zur Panik damit
kann der Körper sehr gut umgehen ob und
wie man da jetzt trotzdem zu
Nahrungsergänzungsmitteln greifen sollte
und ob sich das wirklich lohnt das wäre
eigentlich noch mal ein ganz anderes
Video hier lässt sich aber festhalten
wenn ihr wie ich im Winter gerne einen
optimalen Vitamin D-Spiegel hättet so
quasi just in case dann kann man auf auf
jeden Fall zu Vitamin D Präparaten
greifen da kann man nichts wirklich
falsch machen eine Überdosierung durch
Supplements ist zwar generell möglich
aber laut der ium Werte und dem RKI erst
ab einem 25 ohd Wert von 125 nanomol pro
Liter andere Quellen nennen hier sogar
400 nanomol pro Liter und da muss man
erstmal hinkommen wer es also nicht
drauf anlegt der sollte hier ziemlich
sicher sein am besten wäre es trotzdem
das Ganze einmal mit einem Arzt oder
einer Ärztin zu besprechen die können
dann den Wert im Zweifelsfall für euch
bestimmen muss man n leider meistens
selbst bezahlen wofür ihr jedoch keine
ärztliche Beratung braucht ist Planet
wild dahinter steckt ein Team aus Berlin
das sich konsequent für effektiven
Naturschutz einsetzt wenn ihr schon
immer etwas für den Schutz unseres
Planeten tun wolltet aber noch nicht
wusstet wie genau dann solltet ihr euch
das hier angucken die rewilding
Organisation Planet wild führt nämlich
jeden Monat ein großes
Naturschutzprojekt durch um unseren
Planeten zu schützen und die Schäden zu
beheben die die Menschen der Natur
zufügen finanziert wird das alles über
monatliche Beiträge einer Community von
Menschen die etwas für die Erhaltung der
Ökosysteme unseres Planeten tun möchten
und Ihr könnt direkt sehen was mit euren
Beiträgen erreicht wird Planet wild
dokumentiert jeden Monat in coolen
Videos vor Ort wofür eure Beiträge
eingesetzt werden und was damit in der
Natur bewirkt wird das habe ich so
vorher noch nicht gesehen und deswegen
bin ich selbst Teil der Community ich
find's unglaublich gut und wichtig
wirklich etwas für die Erhaltung unserer
Ökosysteme zu tun und nicht nur darüber
zu reden was man denn mal machen müsste
falls ihr jetzt auch Teil dieser
Community werden wollt dann habe ich ein
besonderes Angebot für euch das es so
vorher noch nicht gab für die ersten 200
Personen die sich über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung bei Planet wild
anmelden werden wir den ersten Monat
bezahlen es lohnt sich also sehr wenn
ihr euch anmeldet vor allem für den
Planeten schaut euch hier die aktuelle
Mission von Planet wild an und bleibt
wie immer neugierig euer
cric